[Music]
a unique holiday tradition in
Newfoundland came roaring back this year
like many celebrations the Mummers
Parade moved online during the pandemic
but this year the Mummers are back
if you're not from Newfoundland there's
a chance you might never have heard of
this unusual festive tradition
disguised in oversized clothes faces
covered and voices mask Mummers barge in
on their neighbors and serenade them
with a folksy tune or a jig the host
tried to guess the identities of their
masked visitors offer up some food and
booze and send them on their way
break the gold suref so you grab some
kind of an Old Lace curtain that your
nan might have had lying around
Jam something on the top of your head
you might wear a big old pair of wool
emits on your hands while its exact
Origins are hazy mummering traces its
roots back to the rightest ancient Roman
Saturn nailia Festival a day of feasting
and celebration were slaves and Masters
would switch places
after the Roman Empire converted to
Christianity some saturnalia customs
were folded into Christian traditions
the word mummering seems to date at
least as far back as the 18th century in
England and Ireland where troops of
amateur actors performed comedic Mummers
plays like Saint George and the Dragon
based on the Christian Legend of Saint
George Who slays a dragon to save a
princess from being sacrificed to the
creature
the play basically you know it entails a
hero and a villain the villain getting
the better of the hero and then he's he
dies and then through magic a doctor
brings our hero back to life
the English and Irish brought mummering
to the new world to cities like
Philadelphia which still holds a Mummers
Parade on New Year's Day mummering first
shows up in Newfoundland and Labrador in
the 1800s but has a dark side Mummers
were mischievous sometimes even violent
and in 1860 newfoundland's government
made it illegal to mummer without a
permit after a man was killed
for a long time there were stories about
there being all sorts of violence in the
1800s with Mummers and that if you were
caught walking down the road in a gang
of Mummers caught up with you they would
beat you with sticks or uh old animal
bladders and they would rip down your
fence or they would tip over your
Outhouse today mummering is still done
by some in communities like Colliers
Riverhead where writer Dennis Flynn is
from we kind of love an excuse to come
and knock on your neighbor's door and go
where you're welcome and to tell a few
stories sing a few songs
a popular song Revitalize the tradition
in the 80s and in the early 2000s the
parade launched in St John's members now
mostly visit seniors and people who are
housebound but in some communities
they're so popular you have to book a
visit from them in advance sometimes
they would get up to a bit of
development
um but not so much anymore where it's a
chance to get together to check in on
senior neighbors make sure they're doing
okay to give them a little bit of
entertainment
um especially in post-pandemic times
Mummers are no longer frightening
characters of lore instead in those rare
communities where people know their
neighbors it's simply a way to spread
some holiday cheer Alyssa Julie Global
News